hot crazy chicks insane cinematography
samurai swords and Gatling guns I'm in
sucker punch
so sucker punch is a story of baby doll
the chick from Lemony Snicket who got
hot after a series of unfortunate events
ends up in the loony bin and to deal
with it her and her friends vision the
loony bin is this burlesque place where
they dance for dudes which I think they
still dance for dudes but they're just
you know in the loony bin now first off
I'll talk about the cinematography in
this movie Zack Snyder's a really visual
director so all the visuals in this
movie are just insane they're badass and
when I first saw a 25-foot tall Shogun
throwing down with a Gatling gun in this
movie I was like I am in but then the
luster of that kind of wears off and
you're like why are these things
happening I mean granted everything
looks awesome it's like these four
scenarios that are just really badass
but I just don't think they fit at all
it plays out like this they need to get
these four objects and then like in real
life in the real world baby doll dances
to distract people and while she's doing
that a crazy scenario happens in which
it's like a metaphor for them getting
the object which they actually end up
getting but I don't see how the scenario
fits with what's happening here it is in
one scenario they need to get a map so
baby doll dances distracts everybody
well one of the other girls goes into
the office and copies a map so all she
does is all right done tack it back up
done and the metaphor for that is
apparently the group of girls fighting a
bunch of Nazi zombies in the trenches of
World War two with mechs it's all about
proper paralleling for something to
parallel something it has to represent
something else example like the zombie
World War two war scene would have made
sense if it was like a dude who was in
war who was like afraid to kill things
so he imagined that his enemies were a
bunch of zombie Nazis so we can get
through it and kill him and the mechs
could have represented something else
you know that's a parallel going into a
boring office and stealing a map only to
have the parallel of that be this crazy
world war 2 scene with zombies I don't
see it other than the fact that they
give us some really cool stuff to look
at it's like you enjoy the first
scenario maybe two and then your brain
kicks on then you wonder why the
scenarios are even happening then you
realize the scenarios are happening
because Zack Snyder thought up four cool
scenarios that he wanted in a movie and
you just kind of made a movie where they
could happen and that's that the movie
would have been really cool is like four
10 minute long webisodes on the internet
that would have been perfect right there
wouldn't have made it
money back for anything but it would
have been cool and I really did like the
music in it the music in this movie is
really good in fact I would call it
badass and all the characters in this
movie are really you know boring they're
all just like we need to get out of here
they'll catch us and kill us already
dead
stuff you've seen in the trailer just
watch the trailer don't pay attention to
any of the cool-looking [ __ ] just look
at the acting you'll notice the
characters are just really boring the
guy who plays the douche though he's
good at playing a douche it took me
forever to realize who he was he's
Prince John in the Robin Hood movie he's
good at playing just like that little
weasel so really hot chicks an awesome
soundtrack cool visuals that apparently
make no sense like if the entire movie
took place in their heads that would be
one thing if the whole thing is like oh
go through these scenarios and you
mentally get free then the dragons and
the weird mechs would make sense so if
you're a person who can just turn his
brain off and appreciate all the really
cool-looking [ __ ] you're gonna buy this
movie even on blu-ray I can't really do
that so I would say it would be a good
time if you're drunk
yeah and now as a party but not too
drunk oh yeah that would be way too
drunk so if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you